[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys wäre gibt
es eine richtig leckere toffifee torte
ich hatte schon mal mit o wie viel torte
gemacht die wir hier in sallys classics
da habe ich einen objekt orte gemacht
also aus meinem ersten oder zweiten tag
gesagt ist das erste buch und die torte
wollte ich jetzt einfach dieses mal ein
bisschen anders gestalten eine torte die
so eigentlich noch keiner gemacht habe
und jetzt gibt es auch gerade eine
deutschlandweite aktion deutschland pakt
mit topf und hier gibt es diese aktion
verpackungen um jeder topf wie viel
verpackung gibt es einen aktionscode den
kann man dann unter www.tk.de einlösen
und umwandeln in einem gutscheincode für
meinen online shop
dann könnte auch alle erst mal aufpassen
und hier unten drin ist der code aber da
gutscheincode ist noch nicht alles denn
hier steht noch was ihr gewinnen könnt
zum gewinnspiel zum richtig großen
gewinnspiel komme ich erst am ende des
videos
zuerst packen wir jetzt nehme ich diese
torte ich habe mir hier eine torte
überlegt mit einem knusprigen christine
beck boden in der mitte ist eine frucht
einlage obendrüber die toffifee creme
die richtig lecker ist und außen herum
habe ich richtig schöne biscuit
schmecken
ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal an mit der
bizkit platte die muss nämlich zuerst
gebacken werden und hier sind die
zutaten
für den bizkit verwende ich für einen
espresso das und 40 milliliter eine
prise salz 120 gramm zucker 100 gramm
mehl und 50 kg für den biskuit nehme ich
jetzt zuerst die eier die kommen in die
rührschüssel da gebe ich das salz und
den zucker dazu und den reisen espresso
die heiße flüssigkeit bewegt nämlich
dass sich die eier bis auf geringe und
fast für die es vergessen man den lake
projekt kommt auch noch rein und dann
wird die eier zuckermasse ganz dick
cremig aufgeschlagen
[Musik]
oh jetzt ist die eier zuckermasse
perfekt und jetzt nämlich einfach das
kakaopulver und das mehl und sie beide
zutaten hinein
[Musik]
jetzt ganz vorsichtig unterheben
jetzt fühle ich den witz quillt in den
wagen ein
den habe ich bereits größtmöglich
eingestellt
[Musik]
ganz schön verteilen
und dann ganz einfach bei 210 grad ober
unterhitze etwa 10 minuten backen
[Musik]
jetzt ist sie biscuit platte gewappnet
und jetzt kann ich sie direkt auf der
back for auslösen
jetzt nämlich ein sauberes auto da kommt
jetzt ein bisschen zucker drauf damit
die bizkit platte nicht drauf klebt
und jetzt ganz vorsichtig zusammen mit
dem geschirrtuch aufrollen
so kommt der bizkit platte nämlich schon
mal in form und kann schnell abkühlen
und wichtig ist dass die platte eben
nicht reist und nicht bricht dass sie
eben nur ganz kurz und heiß gebacken
wird
die biskuitrolle ist es abgekühlt und
jetzt nehme ich sie ganz vorsichtig
auseinander
in der mitte ist noch ein bisschen warm
[Musik]
unterstreiche ich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen aprikosenmarmelade rein
ihr könnt aber auch nur weil sport
marmelade nehmen waldfrucht passt auch
gut weil er später noch waldfrüchte als
frucht einlagerung
[Musik]
und jetzt die biskuitrolle ganz
vorsichtig aufräumen unternehmen die am
besten das tuch von ein bisschen zu
hilfe und drückt ganz ganz vorsichtig
zusammen
[Musik]
und dann wirklich das restliche doch
noch ein bisschen außen rum
und lass die rolle so ein bisschen
ziehen
weiter geht's mit dem nobel boden dafür
verwende ich 60 gramm butter 15 hoffen
60 gramm löffel bist wird um 20 gramm
amaranth pops zuerst nämlich jetzt die
butter die kommt hier in einen kleinen
topf und kann geschmolzen werden und
dann kann ich hier in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die toffifee nehmen und
zerkleinern der mir in der mitte diese
schöne haselnuss und die möchte ich
jetzt ein bisschen verkleinern und die
werden dann mit geschmolzen
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich die zerkleinerten topfit
so geschmolzener butter und lass dir ein
bisschen mit schmerzen
was wird ein leckerer no big boden
hier stelle ich jetzt auch die hitze
ganz weit runter damit nichts verbrennt
und kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal
die kekse zerkleinern
und das könnte jetzt entweder so wie ich
hier im mixer machen oder die kekse auch
einfach in einem gefrierbeutel mit dem
ausland verkleinern
jetzt ist die masse cheng geschmolzen
und jetzt gebe ich da die kekse dazu und
auch die am rand pops und am rand das
kenne ich vom müsli oder vom müsliriegel
und zwar ist es so eine art getreide
ersatz ziemlich eisenhaltig als ich
nehme es auch ganz gern für mein müsli
und ja das ist so das ist jetzt gepackt
die gibt's auch unter problem sind ein
bisschen härter und knuspriger und fallt
ihr die nicht habt und auch nicht
bekommt wobei die gibt es in jeder
drogerie und im gut sortierten
supermarkt dann können auch einfach
mandl nehmen oder mehr kekse also
hauptsache irgendwie ihren festen
bestandteilen aber die passen hier schon
ganz gut jetzt dem masse schön verrühren
ich erzähle auch schön diese haselnüsse
da drin und es riecht halt richtig schön
nach lukas schokolade karamell jetzt
nämlich hier einen bug ring und stellt
den aufnahmen paten retter schneit noch
ein backpapier zurecht das mache ich
immer so einfach zum tüte falten dann in
die mitte und einmal aus dem raum mit
der schere
dann habt ihr einen fast perfekten
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt die masse reinen wird
schön platt gedrückt das könnte jetzt
entweder mit der hand machen oder auch
mit einem klar
oder ihr nehmt einfach die bürger presse
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich den boden für etwa zehn
minuten kurz den kühlschrank
[Musik]
und für die frucht einlage verwende ich
200 milliliter wasser 250 gramm tief
gefrorene früchte und etwas ag mit
nämlich einfach die zutaten also das
wasser und stedefreund früchte die habe
ich jetzt auch ein bisschen auftauen
lassen
gib sie hier rein und kann sie ganz
prosperieren
[Musik]
dann kommen die zutaten hier in einen
topf
hier kommen dann massaker mit rein das
ist ein pflanzliches geliermittel und da
ist es ganz wichtig dass das ganze auf
gekocht wird und dann muss es zwei vor
die und kochen damit dass agave wirken
kann und eben auch schon fest wird
[Musik]
stolz sind die früchte fertig jetzt muss
ich natürlich meiner frucht einlage eine
form geben
ich lebe jetzt hier einfach einen teller
da kommt frischhaltefolie rein ich hatte
jetzt keine folie also habe ich ein
gefrierbeutel aufgeschnitten und füllen
das jetzt hier rein
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel und
schälchen nehmen und so wie die form von
dem schild vom teller ist so wird dann
auch die frucht einlage manchmal nämlich
auch ein tortenring die kuppel die wird
jetzt auch schon
[Musik]
und dann am besten bei raumtemperatur
kurz ein bisschen abkühlen lassen und
dann ab in den kühlschrank oder direkt
in die gefriertruhe
[Musik]
für die creme verwende ich 500 gramm
sahne 24 toffifee 500 gramm quark und
etwas seiner partei für die creme lasse
ich jetzt die sache in einem kleinen
topf aufkochen und gibt dann die
toffifee mit hinein
jetzt kann ich sie durch früheren
auflösen und da ist er jetzt der
haselnuss kern mit drin und den filter
ich jetzt einfach raus
[Musik]
und wenn ihr das vorher schon dran denke
dann könnt ihr die haselnuss gerne auch
zerkleinern und direkt in den no big
boden mit reingehen nicht verstehen
versucht spielen
und jetzt ist ganz wichtig dass diese
creme abkühlt im kühlschrank und wieder
auf kühlschranktemperatur kommt
ansonsten gewinnen nämlich die sanierung
aufschlagen
also kurz kühl stellen jetzt geht's ans
befüllen der torte den no big boden habe
ich ja da unten drin
jetzt kommt die biskuitrolle und die
schneide ich jetzt in ein zentimeter
breiter schreiben
[Musik]
und dann nehmen wir sie und legt sie an
den rand der torte also direkt an den
backen
die gräben sind gut abgekühlt und jetzt
kommt hier noch der quark mit rein
denn die zutaten kurz berührt
jetzt kann ich mit seiner party creme
steif schlagen
[Musik]
die creme ist völlig sie in einen
spritzbeutel ein mit großer lockt schule
so lässt sich die torte nämlich besser
und einfacher berühren
[Musik]
die frucht einlage ist jetzt fest sie
ist noch nicht gefroren aber bei der
größe ist es auch gar nicht schlimm
die wird jetzt hier eingesetzt und dann
kommt da die torten creme drauf und ich
befehle jetzt hier zuerst den rand der
torte
und dann kommt die restliche creme auch
in dem match dann wird die creme noch
schön verstrichen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die torte abdecken und
dann für etwa drei bis vier stunden kühl
stellen
jetzt ist die torte gut durch gekühlt
ich hab sie bereits auf eine
tortenplatte gesetzt der abend lässt
sich ganz einfach wegnehmen so sieht's
jetzt aus und so gefällt sie mir auch
schon ziemlich gut jetzt möchte ich die
oberfläche mit toffifee dekorieren und
mit früchten und weil wir keine früchte
saison haben gibt es natürlich keine
frischen früchte gefrorene früchte nehme
ich jetzt nicht auf der oberfläche weil
sie ansonsten matschig werden wenn sie
aufbauen
also greife ich hier auf
gefriergetrocknete früchte zurück die
sie nämlich schön trocken haben keine
feuchtigkeit und zu matschen nicht da
habe ich jetzt himbeeren erdbeeren blau
werden brombeeren und sauerkirschen und
die nehme ich jetzt und macht sondern
schönen kranz aus warum teilweise
zerbröseln teilweise im ganzen drauf und
dann kommt noch drauf
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die fertige torte aus
lieber morath so darfst sie gleich
probieren ich erzähle euch aber noch ein
bisschen was über das gewinnspiel in
jeder toffifee verpackung gibt es einen
aktionscode diesen aktionscode kann man
dann bis zum 14 10 2009 10 auf trophée
de einlösen und dann erfahrt ihr auch
direktor gerne preis gewonnen habt
anschließend erhaltet ihr automatisch
einen gutscheincode für meinen online
shop und den könnt ihr dort dann bis zum
30.9 einlösen
deswegen lohnt es sich auf jeden fall
mitzumachen zu gewinnen gibt's nämlich
fünf bosch war ist ein kühlschränke mit
wechselbarer front so wie ich ihn zu
hause schon stehen habe den kitsch made
küchenmaschinen in der limitierten farbe
petrol von ranshofen punkt kommt zehnmal
das bak starterset von meinem shop 100
toffifee sets mit wachs schürze und
toshiba kann schon und 1000 mal dass vw
backbuch schon krasse gewinner oder
wachs zu verbergen lieber murat na klar
so ist dem kommt prima klima vor die
kamera wir sehen ja ich habe lange
überlegt was wenn die torte ich mache
und habe dann überlegt mit rib cache
aber so ein trip cache den gibt es halt
schon im bankbuch deswegen dachte ich
komme mal was anderes und habe mich dann
für eine torte entschieden die
eigentlich auch jeder nachmachen kann
und trotzdem genial und ich glaube
topmodel glaub ich auf jeder feier
glauben und ich glaube trophy hier mit
frucht es haben noch nicht viele gemacht
[Musik]
ich habe tolle zur pause haben sie schon
viele gewünscht als video als wir das
noch nicht gemacht also ich probiere es
erst mal hier ich hab halt die toffifee
unten im boden und die creme ist und
welche creme und der beste deshalb weiß
ich dass ich den boden was ich ja ich
gebacken ich frage nur lieb ist rolle
also wenn nötig machen möchte das
einfach die biskuitrolle weg und machen
diesen opec boden mit frucht einlage und
kräftig mal cool wenn ich habe erstens
wissen wir mit traudel ist wenn die
creme und dem papier noch hinten die
biskuitrolle caravelle trolle eigen
gemacht
dem ist aber sagt das nicht so sicher
und genial werden jetzt verschiedene
geschmacksrichtungen wie schokolade
du hast mit dem du hast und du hast
natürlich das besondere extra toffifee
also falls ihr diese torte nach machen
möchtet dann schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei aufs ellis - blog.de macht auf
jeden fall beim gewinnspiel mit ich
drücke euch allen ganz ganz feste die
daumen und postet eure gewinne falls ihr
gewonnen habt und postet natürlich auch
gerne eure torte mit diesem versteckt
und macht auf jeden fall diese pistole
ein die ich mal richtig den jahre
mitglied war das auch noch einmal ja
jetzt doch noch mal und noch mal da rein
hauen kann man auch machen weil die bis
getrocknet da noch einiges übrig wer
möchte kann zum beispiel noch eine
schicht biskuitrolle offen boden geben
würde anlage drauf schmidt sogar
wirklich ganz ehrlich dann hätte ich
auch so machen können also dann macht
ihr es auf jeden fall so kostet uns ein
foto wird nächsten mal aus was der guten
weg mit am rand und ging es aber nicht
nur den boden würde ich nun mal
reinmachen will ich mit
finke beim gewinnspiel
[Musik]